bro there was a video
where
i forget where this if it was in the old
cky stuff it was in earlier stuff with
you guys but they rented a car and got
the full insurance on the car
and then
lit the car on fire and destroyed the
car okay i'm gonna i hate i hate to
[ __ ] uh do it he tells about the
story all the time he's like the best i
thought it was the craziest thing i've
ever seen so happen
you just weren't looking closely
if i found out you didn't drink [ __ ]
i [ __ ] ate [ __ ] dude
but i think here here's the story and i
kind of not mad at him but like
but but there was uh
what happened
and that the inspiration for that bit
and apologies to bamford for revealing
this if it's not widely out there anyway
it's pretty obvious in the clip but they
were coming home from like a skate
session or something like driving down
the road and like what the [ __ ] there's
a car over there on fire like so they
were like they were like they they
pulled over they found a car on fire
they pulled over they got this footage
of the car on fire and they're like what
are we gonna do with this [ __ ]
footage of the car on fire and and bam
was like dude he came up with the genius
idea
let's go let's go rent uh a car
let's go and let's go rent a car
and say that we paid for the insurance
and then end up with the car blowing up
and this is you know
you can't be mad at him for that but the
thing is that like the car they rented
was
like a totally different shape
dude oh wait are there other things like
that there weren't cky was littered with
like say for example when they're um
kicking the footballs
into the cars yeah like you can
recognize like every [ __ ] person who
gets out of the car after the football
has been kicked into it as like one of
their family members
you know i respect it more now yeah like
a little part of me is like wow you
understood production value you
understand how to get around these
things and how to i guess trick the
world out that is
i mean it's uh
is we man really a dwarf
what else is going on
jackass was very
uh like high on integrity you know there
were there are precious few things on
jackass that were manipulated
in a deceitful way at all give me give
me what like what when
when i did the the butt chug
right it was completely real the jackass
number two that i put a beer bong in
here in my [ __ ] and they they uh pour
the beer in and chugging like you see
that there's no faking that the as i
kick my legs you see the level of beer
in the hose lower and lower it's all
going on my ass
but but when uh
but wait but when they took the plunger
right and like uh to plunge it and all
this beer comes out of the plunger like
that's one thing off camera they poured
a little beer into the plunger where did
it go if it was all going up in your ass
oh i [ __ ] out a [ __ ] on a beer too but
but but when he was plunging my beard
like just what spilled out of the
plunger that was important
it's like it's a very minor thing but in
the world of jackass and the level of
integrity that we always had
like that's a big deal
wow yeah the other thing i know of
uh
bmx tug of war
that was
[ __ ] phenomenal
like um
they uh they had ryan dunn sitting on
the stove with a rope tied around him
and they do the bmx you know
and uh
it played in the movie as a split screen
you know you see like the
the bike on on the one screen and you
see it done flying off the sofa on the
other
but it was just the like the logistics
of
of the stunt like ryan wasn't getting
pulled off the sofa by the it wasn't
enough to pull him and make him go
flying with just the bike yeah so they
that's why it was split screen they set
up like the the biking you know on the
the one shot and then on the ryan dunn
shot split screen they just had like you
know a bunch of guys like pull the yeah
pull the uh
yeah yeah i mean they [ __ ] pulled his
ass off and started [ __ ] hard and
flew him into a bunch of cacti so like
you know you can't get too mad at that
either does anything happen to your guys
balls like you get hit in the balls a
lot and and like
can you have kids you know uh as part of
my my um
my bucket list tour yeah and what i was
going to tell you before is that um
with with all these crazy stunts and
like how high level they are like i'm
proud of um
that it's clever in that
the backdrop like
the the theme of the show is the
implications of me carrying out all of
these various stunts
on my relationship with my fiance you
know that's it it's a love story and
that's why in that opening sequence i've
got the flowers because the whole story
is a love story about my relationship
and everything in the show is inspired
and the narrative
is uh
throughout is my relationship so in the
show when i come to the point of uh so
we're getting married i'm engaged and
you know you can't
make you can't take that leap without
agreeing on the kid question of course
and neither of us want um kids oh really
right so
uh because [ __ ] kids
no why you have the opportunity to be
this very present father and you know
right the wrongs that happen to you i
mean did i tell you by my mom's side of
the family
to make sure they don't drink but is
that what you're worried about
i mean there's there's a genetic
component there's there's just the uh
i'm not very bearish on the world
right right right i'm sorry i'm not
bullish
yeah yeah i'm not embarrassed yeah yeah
embarrassing on the world yeah yeah [ __ ]
my dad be bummed on that one
but uh but yeah i just think that the
whole disparity of wealth the rich
getting richer the poor getting poor the
dwindling opportunity i don't want it on
my conscience that i created a [ __ ]
person to struggle with all that what do
you mean dwindling opportunity and i had
an idea on my bucket list called the
vasectomy olympics
also that right
what is this about well when i was i
just wanted to know you've made probably
millions of dollars
ingesting calm and like kicking the ball
that's why you can't have any kids he's
gonna be eating all his comments
yeah you're just greedy
there's so much opportunity like if if
you can exist with what you're doing in
america this doesn't happen outside of
america right this is the land of
opportunity my my dad when he heard my
plan for the vasectomy olympics yeah
which was initially inspired by a bad
joke i heard in seventh grade which was
what is the definition of macho
a man who jogs home from his own
vasectomy
and i i didn't give a [ __ ] at the time
i'm 12 years old but i just wanted to be
macho so i remembered the joke i grew up
with the idea that i was going to get a
vasectomy and just do way more than jog
and it'd be super super much
but before
filming the vasectomy and the stunts
which were epic that we did afterwards
yeah
i knew that i had a finite amount of
time to answer the question
that you asked
what about your balls can you have kids
with all of the trauma to the balls
and so i could not pass up the
opportunity to go to a fertility clinic
oh wow and get a sperm count before my
vasectomy to answer the questions the
average man has roughly 20 to 30 million
sperm per milliliter of jizz
and i clocked in at 51 million there you
[ __ ] go but they're all done
scott
he was very average on the count but
there are more criteria to the sperm
yeah which i don't draw a lot of
attention to
like i
every year to keep that load
cryogenically frozen just in case not
because i think i'm going to change my
mind but because i've got a [ __ ] idea
for that
let's go
who's that who's that load going in bro
it's not going in anyone it's going on a
plate with they're like a mr beast of
[ __ ]
come content ideas right i mean dude
like here's
this idea was inspired by uh it was
depressed and lacy came up with it
inspired by an experience we had in
mexico where i took a vial of my beloved
ketamine poured it on a glass table and
dried it out with a hair dryer into
instant until it was fully dry and i
scraped it up
into a line and snorted it and pressed
and said dude man what if what if he
[ __ ] blew a load on the table and
dried that and snorted that
and i thought wow great idea but one
load's probably not going to cut it
we're going to need the whole cast
to blow a load and so i want to
contribute
no alex i want to contribute to that
when you hung out with your friends when
you did spring break
did any one of them say like yo do you
guys want to all nut in this table wait
till the eyes and then we just snort it
together
hair actually dries
maybe put it in uh like a dehydration
you need a good process
because that way you're not you know
that way you can get a good time lapse
of of the [ __ ] drawing um
it's just so funny too because if you've
ever snorted coke you know like it lands
in the back of your throat
and like
my synapses are firing
[Applause]
you